données hors données 58 ans voulait fait
pas du tout c'est incroyable merci alors
vraiment à faire une interview 58 ans
est ce que comme tous les mecs de 58 ans
vous aimez bien qu'on vous le dit ce que
vous ne faites pas votre âge
oh oui oui ça me fait plaisir est ce que
comme tous les mecs de 58 ans vous avez
la pression quand même chaque fois que
vous rentrez dans un lit avec une fille
c'est bien si tu as la pression c'est
quand au delà plus qu il est prêt à
parler avec comme unique pour trente ans
on a 30 ans est ce que comme tous les
mecs de 58 ans vous essayé de draguer
des jeunes dans les boîtes
est ce que comme tous les mecs de 58 ans
vous surveillez votre taux de
cholestérol
ah non ah non non je surveille d'autres
trucs mais ça nous quoi bon aller très
vite chez les check-points ont fait
moins que vous d'ailleurs moi j'en fais
un tous les deux trois ans est ce que
comme tous les mecs de 58 ans vous
regrettez les vinyles a pas du tout
avant un écart et non pas du tout je
trouve cette mode suspecte j'étais au
contraire tellement heureux quand les
camps le cd est arrivé à tous ces
problèmes ont donné une bande avec une
certaine qualité qui sortait du studio
et quand on entendait le vini c'était à
pleurer paraît tellement la différence
était grande
ah non il ne s'agit des vinyles ah non
une question maintenant sur laquelle
vous risquez sur une réponse mans à
l'ombre mais bon c'est comme tous les
mecs de 58 ans vous prenez du viagra
sans le dire non alors il y a
coût
non vous n'oubliez pas que mon rein papa
était nette
oui d'accord mais tendent à donner au
cheval est ce que comme tous les mecs de
58 ans vous croyez vous avez toujours 20
ans non je crois pas que j'ai 20 ans
parce que je crois que j'étais moins
bien dans des clarks à 20 ans
qu'aujourd'hui
moi oui maintenant je crois pas que j'ai
20 ans mais pour certaines choses oui je
le pense
justement vous avez justement est ce que
comme tous les mecs de 58 en bout était
à droite parce que vous avez peur un peu
quand même pour vous c'est à dire c'est
affreux c'est pas bien de dire mais je
vote pas donc voila quoi j'ai un petit
peu honte de le dire est ce que comme
tous les mecs de 58 ans vous avez peur
de mourir
est-ce que françoise hardy vous a dit un
truc qui fait flipper quand elle dit
brest et lille à 20 heures elle a fêté
la regarder il a elle vous l'a fait ça
françoise hardy seulement fait elle m'a
fait plusieurs fois elle est forte ont
plombé l'ambiance sur elle l'a fait
plusieurs fois mon thème mais elle m'a
jamais parlé de deux de ces termes là et
c'est comme tous les mecs de 58 ans vous
serez vous êtes encore pas mal pour
votre âge ah oui absolument
qu'est ce t'en penses il te plaît
beaucoup